et bien tout le monde sait aujourd'hui
on se retrouve une nouvelle fois sur
gold simulateur parce qu'il ya eu plein
de contenus coûts été ajoutés par les
joueurs donc les ouates
il m'a surpris le coup et ce qui tend
qu'à une porte alors attendez on va les
voir tout ça de plus près c'est le
starter pour rejoindre ces gens mais
wayne mais c'est une [ __ ] de sectes
quoi pour la secte dedans et je peux la
howie aller relève toi ça suffit à est
de simuler un lumbago un très bien donc
on a des gens qui font du trampoline
watts
c'est l'heure du mur invisible mais qui
s'il a lui ce qu'il a voulu cacher sa
calvitie avec un mouchoir
ce ne sont pas des choses qui se font
mais me fait flipper ce mec sans
déconner il est meilleur look et voici
la particularité de ma chèvre la fièvre
terroriste caresser mois ceci est un
ordre cela pose est ce que ceci est une
invitation c'est quoi ces mouvements
[ __ ] j'y arrive pas à comprendre
arrêté un tueur changera tour ce niveau
c'est très bien donc là ok donc là whaou
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est moi
qui fait sa ba c'est une autre manière
de danser finalement
avoir jeté mais oui tu merde merde
oh mais non on dirait une sorte d'oiseau
un peu plus viril qui est un pigeon
normal il a aucun [ __ ] de style oh
[ __ ] mais il est des coudes crâne
chauve c'est ça regardez moi ce à quoi
l'a voulu ben qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est
ce qui a été pas content tu te crois vos
insultes parce que cette clôture et
manon bon gars la discrétion scène est
d'un ridicule plutôt adhérentes à nom
annonce haye et c'était le pas de trop
ou des victimes d'un amour fusionnel tu
arrêtes je sens le truc grotesque voilà
j'aurais été sur péno mais qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait j'avais surtout que
cette chèvre a embroché un bonhomme de
neige
je peux jouer un drôle d'air bag dans
une voiture sans problème la commande
avec vous à ça veut dire que ça va pas
je vais résoudre tous tes problèmes pour
une bonne thérapie ne pas traverser les
murs gris ce petit corps de poulet avec
c'est ce gros crâne coach le web mais
moins vite
attention avait esquivé au bon moment
automne chicken top chicken plus pour
longtemps
c'est pas grave c'est exactement ce que
je voulais voilà allez je m'en vais
aller tu prends la 4c grèce ah mais non
mais arrête je t'aime et donne plus que
tout tu étais en idole pour moi quoi bon
john j'ai vu ta petites jalousies à
temps puisqu'il ya un poteau qui
m'attaquent bat comme un poteau entre
nous puis tu t'assois dessus a pas de
problème voilà bien viens là dedans a
plus
ou tu es tu es foutu où tu es tu john
john o l'amour nous a réunis alors est
ce que c'est un pied ou si l'horloge
c'est une simple question oh non il est
de retour ont la taille de la fièvre
alors le pervers des chèvres tu veux un
thoër qu il n'y a pas de problème tiens
c'est gratuit c'est génial
brottes arrête personne ne se doute de
ce que je suis et soudainement et mime
regarder quoi la chèvre en position
foetale arrête roches ou quelqu'un peut
jouer à la pétanque ou le joli fait ce
plan this reason mission personne ne m'a
repéré personne ne lui a repéré wii
rouge
peut passer le balai avec cet homme
allait bien voilà comme ça allait aller
voici la plus grosse fête du monde la
version cher qu'est ce que je suis en
train de faire c'est bon ou j'appelle
mon grand frère
vous allez le regretter tu as arrêté au
petit frère ah mais non monsieur côté
flag que c'est moi yep allégerait coup
on y va non je craque c'était pas leur
ont offert le robot mais non mais qu'est
ce qui fait bouger avec le moins visible
est en train de lui faire la blague ou
il le tire par le caleçon vous avez qui
limite les robots aspirateurs l'arête ya
rien a inspiré à mais c'est carrément
glauque
est ce que c'est une manière de se
reposer ça un nom et dégage alors une
nouvelle fièvre
ah oui d'accord une demie chèvre c'est
ça on dirait des wc voix c'est de mettre
sa tête à l'intérieur de mon corps
talbot qui a des idées de psychopathe
mais [ __ ] je veux juste qu'une telle
taille dans mon ventre mais arrêter
personne ne peut entrer dans mon corps
de chèvre c'est carrément pas un animal
ou dire l espèce de gros seins qu'on
mange la les oursons c'est dégueulasse
mais sagement ce truc ça ne se joue pas
garder le tout flasque quoi c'est génial
attends tu vas bien par les toits au
back flip breton est élastique ça ne
touche pas les fesses tu m'as
sous-estimé je ne comprend pas du tout
pourquoi on comprend mieux désormais
retire cette part de mes fesses dégage
vous avez vraiment un pas de danse
classique quoi nous allons désormais
découvrir la chèvre qui mangent beaucoup
de fast food aux tchèques mon gros cul
nouvelles missions passées entre des
passants avec une chèvre obèses sans les
toucher
oh là ou là ou là ou là je sais que vous
allez mourir mais c'est pas une raison
un [ __ ] dans la tête est passé mais je
crois qu'il fait ce de façon voilà voilà
voilà maintenant gros cul vue attendez
attendez je crois que ma chèvre évolué
attendait aux yeux un nouveau super voix
fait son apparition dans les villes
super shayk superchunk retourne à
accomplir sa mission
attendez au nom ça change tout j'étais
persuadé que c'était une femelle
bon du coup voulu trouver une copine
quand même hop le fait de house hop
non non mais n'ayez pas peur je suis je
suis un mâle mais n'ai pas peur il ya
des gens en dessous
ah oui désolé c'est par ici la fête dit
quoi tout est fait comme si j'étais pas
là continuez c'est l'heure de vous
présenter un tout nouveau super héros
jambes élastique cas cette girafe est
inquiétante
c'est pas comme ça que l'escale à john
girafe on a voulu faire la fête sont
gisèle alors non non non jour 1
c'est quoi cette chèvre quoi oh oui oh
c'est ça qu'on veut année ça se
transforme en poissons si j'ai la droite
religieuse c'est le chien pour ses notes
religieuse une mante religieuse a
rejoint la manifestation
ou alors un fusil à pompe l'on peut
croire que ça fusil à pompe la vente
religieuse poisson dans l'eau
mais c'est quoi ce truc
et voilà les gens c'est déjà fin de
cette troisième vidéo sur goltv la teuf
j'espère que ça vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo si c'est le cas ça me
fera plaisir on se retrouve bientôt dans
une nouvelle vidéo
tu as tout le monde